I'm so obsessed with it already everyone
at some point of my life thinks about
getting a tattoo I've thought about it
five times tattoos I think are magical
there's something about him that has the
power to heal last year I got a tattoo
to memorialize my aunt who passed away
and it was one of the most empowering
moments of my life so I want to share
that experience with other people which
is why I'm on a mission to find other
people powerful stories and hook them up
with their dream tattoo welcome to first
ink
[Music]
I'm sure half of people in LA have
tattoos better he ever tattooed what
about the rest of you guys say we hear
us cut twos in the car top how many we
are driving from our by speed campus in
Hollywood all the way to Santa Barbara
we're gonna be meeting Claire who's a
student who's gonna be getting her first
ink today she has a very powerful story
it's pretty difficult subject matter but
I went through hundreds of submissions
for this Claire stood out the most we're
gonna cure her story which is very
compelling we're gonna find out about
her tattoo what she has in mind and hook
her up with some dope tattoo art it's
kind of a story with good things and bad
things and with this tattoo I'm trying
to reflect the good things that came out
of it around January this year I was
sexually assaulted by my boss I was out
getting drinks with coworkers he offered
to walk me home and the next thing I
knew we were in bed together and he was
taking off a used condom when it first
happened I was really really deep in
denial I was having anxiety attacks
panic attacks I was diagnosed with PTSD
and I was still going to work with him
it took me the longest time to say it
out loud and say I was assaulted like I
was raped having people there to tell
you like no it's not your fault it helps
me feel a lot more comfortable and
telling other people so I want this
tattoo to represent the people who are
there for me when I needed them the most
so you're gonna get flowers to represent
friends and family who supported you
yeah this is my studio I've been
tattooing why did my first one in like
14 years ago is that legal
my rebellious teen years sort of led me
to hangout and taxi shops that are young
age how would you describe your tattoo
style painterly illustrative floral is
my concentration I would say flowers can
represent a lot of different things and
be subtle at the same time it's a
classic timeless piece to have a flower
when Claire and I first spoke she wanted
to work with you the most yeah yeah
you're so talented are you ready to see
some designs here are a few watercolors
that I came up with I really like this
middle one okay I really love the colors
on it okay the shape is nice and that
you like this size yeah this is a great
size when I put the stencil on you we
can adjust it I just think we need to
yeah that's the one
that's your first tattoo right there you
happy with the design happy with the
placement of course that's a substantial
piece right there that I mean this is no
joke my first piece was the size of a
quarter so I'm committed you're jumping
right in are you ready to get your first
ink yes let's go
[Music]
like it's not bad but it definitely is
not comfortable either like if you had a
bad sunburn and someone just kept poking
at it what's beautiful how have you been
coping with the pain the first two and a
half hours went by really quickly now
that it's getting more sensitive it's a
little bit harder I should do it
Mallory's she's sitting really well and
then press I'm kind of jealous right now
it's pretty addicting I did not in the
negative sense in like once you do it
you want to do it again you get your
first one you realize that this wasn't
my big of a deal like you don't think
about it that much when somebody gets
one tattoo you they really intend on
getting others even if they don't know
it you know we're about four and a half
hours in
I wanted to report it because this was a
guy who was working with some of my
closest friends and I was worried that
he would try to do the same thing he did
to me to someone else
that I cared about it was arranged that
i was going to have a phone call with
the CEO to discuss the matter I wasn't
sure if the company would be discreet I
wasn't sure if they would believe me I
was scared of what my co-workers would
think of me if it got out I ended up
texting my friend who lives in San Diego
he in the middle of the night drove up
said I want to be with you during that
call the next day my friend calls me up
and she says oh my gosh our boss just
got fired and I was so happy in that
moment I had my friend who drove up from
San Diego and the friend who gave me the
phone call pick out flowers lavender and
poppy my experience was painful tattoo
is a little painful but you can find
beautiful things in it and just to help
some like empower some women to reclaim
their body is through the process of
getting tattooed and it makes it even
more rewarding how close are we malory
we're done we're done you have
successfully completed your first tattoo
I'm really excited to see the final
results okay do you want to check it out
oh my gosh I love it I feel like I'm in
shock a little bit I couldn't have
gotten about our first tattoo like this
I'm so obsessed with it already how do
you think your friends and family will
react to this new addition my friends
are really gonna like it my family
they're gonna be surprised at least are
you gonna tell them yeah cuz I don't
want to have to hide it all my life
is one of your friends here yeah as it
is one of the flowers how do you think
the tattoo came out I think it's
beautiful I think it's everything I
expected and more she has a lavender on
her ankle as well so you guys had twins
so I hope that anyone watching this who
is going through a similar situation
knows that people will have their back
and they can speak out too
[Music]
but no I feel a little bit like Santa
Claus right now yeah I feel a little bit
like tatoo Santa Claus right now tattoo
Santa Claus